evening everyone welcome to the next
revolution i'm steve hilton this is the
home of positive populism pro worker
pro family pro community and especially
pro america
look what we've seen the past few weeks
adam toledo aged 13 shot and killed in
chicago macau bryant aged
16 shot and killed in columbus ohio
anthony thompson
17 shot and killed in knoxville
tennessee these
terrible stories have been used as
fodder
for the only debate the left seems to
want these days
about race but we need to stop and think
about what we're really seeing
there's no conceivable reason for a 13
year old to be wandering the streets at
2 40 a.m with a gun
for a 16 year old to be screaming and
fighting in broad daylight
armed with a knife for a 17 year old to
hide a gun in his hoodie
at school none of us is a perfect
parent in a position to judge life is
incredibly tough for many people
but there's something going terribly
wrong in america it's so
deep and so personal makes many people
so uncomfortable
that we just ignore it but it's not
going away the problem is getting worse
the problem the crisis is the collapse
of family in america
you see it in those stories you see it
in the numbers
where we once talked about divorce and
family breakup today families are not
even being formed in the first place
our marriage rate is at its lowest ever
recorded
nearly a quarter of american children
live with one parent and no other adult
more than three times the rate in the
rest of the world
in 2019 40 percent of children
were born outside marriage
nearly half a million american children
in foster care without either parent
half a million you see the consequences
all around us not just those in gangs or
mixed up in crime and disorder but in
every day everywhere
collapse of civilized standards course
aggressive rude
disrespectful behavior children addicted
to phones and screens at an earlier and
earlier age
incapable of forming real healthy human
relationships
it is a social and economic disaster
it's an economic disaster because we
know that a stable family
makes a huge difference to life chances
and opportunity
if you're born in the bottom twenty
percent of the income scale
your chances of reaching the top 20 are
four times higher if your parents stay
married your chances of staying in the
bottom 20
if your parents never married it's 50
50. but if your parents are married it
drops to just 17
marriage makes a massive difference in
keeping families stable
on average if parents are married three
quarters are still together by the time
their child is 12
if they're just living together it's
only a quarter
the normalization of broken families is
a social disaster too because
substance abuse mental illness and crime
are all more common
in disrupted families this is not
moralizing
it's the facts the data remember how
we're told to
follow that not when it comes to the
issue of family it seems
no one wants to talk about it because
family breakdown and families not being
formed in the first place is just so
widespread people don't want to seem
judgmental
but actually the liberal elite are
they look down their noses at the
prioritization of stable families
even if it comes from obama when he
dared talk about the importance of
strong families
he was slammed by the left of course
not every child of married parents is
guaranteed a perfect life but we've
shown you the facts
marriage is statistically better for
children
better for society than the alternative
a lot better
yet for decades the establishment has
pushed policies in the tax and welfare
systems
that undermine marriage and family
stability and biden's recent bailout
bill
well it more than doubled payments to
single parents the elite
reject all this by saying it's crazy to
argue that people make these decisions
based on financial incentives
but if financial incentives make no
difference why do they want subsidies
for electric cars
or solar panels or all the other things
they want more of
well if you care about poverty
inequality social mobility
crime substance abuse mental health as
we have comprehensively established
with the data you should want to see
more stable families which means
more marriage so let's incentivize that
for goodness sake is there anything
more deserving of subsidy as with so
many things with the establishment their
furious opposition
to policies that promote family
stability is the most enormous hypocrisy
because there is actually one part of
our society where family stability is
going up
not down where marriage rates are
increasing not falling
yep among the rich and educated
and in fact there's another place
marriage
is increasing gay and lesbian americans
are getting married i think that's great
it's a vote of confidence in one of the
institutions conservatives most cherish
so i've always been for marriage
equality in fact i believe in marriage
equality so much
i even think straight people should get
married if they want to raise a family
the marriage problem in america is not
that gay people aren't getting married
it's that straight people aren't we must
rebuild the american family and that
starts with marriage
raising a family is hard as tim scott
said this week single parents do a
heroic job
but it's not a criticism of single
parents to state plainly
that it's better for a child to be
raised by two parents not one
so first we must end the insanity of
incentivizing single parenthood
it's great to see a number of republican
senators are working on plans to do just
that and one of them marsha blackburn
will be here tonight
then we must positively encourage
marriage like they do in other countries
in israel certain tax credits are only
available to adults who are married
in japan couples can get over five
thousand dollars for getting married in
hungary which has recently become a
world leader in pro-family policy new
couples
can get subsidized loans which are
completely forgiven if they have three
children together
and here senator josh hawley has a
parent tax credit plan
that gives married couples an extra six
thousand dollars a year
but it'll take more than financial
incentives to rebuild the american
family
one of the reasons marriage rates have
collapsed in working class communities
is the destruction of steady jobs for
men so we need to stop the college for
all elitism
given another disastrous push by biden
this week
and divert much of the money we
currently put into higher education
into skills-based vocational training
boosting that was a huge untold success
story of the trump administration by the
way an effort led
by ivanka trump who was also behind the
most pro-family move by any
administration in decades
the trump administration's expansion of
family leave that's so
important because research shows that
stressful times like having a newborn in
the house
are when most breakups happen family
relationships parenting is the most
important thing we ever do
and it's ridiculous that there's so
little help on offer it doesn't need to
be the nanny state
local community organizations faith
groups they can play a much bigger role
the democrats want government to play a
much bigger role
just listen to this from biden's
domestic policy chief
susan rice last week quote we want
parents to be in the workforce
especially mothers oh do you susan rice
well who made you the boss
of every mother in america according to
recent research
most mothers actually don't want to be
in full-time work they'd rather be
full-time parents or doing
part-time work the point is it should be
their choice not susan rice's choice
raising kids is contributing to the
economy it's the most important work
anyone can do and we should reward it
not
punish it or try and make parents who
stay at home second class citizens
and no this doesn't mean women in the
kitchen and men as breadwinners a third
of wives
out earn their husbands each family is
different and they
should decide but the democrats don't
want
parents to decide they want nationalized
child care all parents forced out to
work with government handouts to pay
someone else to look after their
children
the plan biden just announced it was
tried in canada
and this was the result according to vox
quote
kids were worse off so we must fight the
nightmare of the left's
industrialized factory child care there
is a more conservative
way a more human way to help families
community-based marriage and parent
coaching
nurse family partnerships where a nurse
visits a family's home regularly
to help make sure everything's on track
we need to look at everything in this
way
does it support or undermine families
people are waking up to the
woke indoctrination going on in our
public schools
but for even longer there's been an
anti-family bias
in the system a moral ecology which
devalues stable families
you don't see that so much in
independent schools those run by faith
organizations
it's yet another reason to end the
public school monopoly and put power in
parents hands
these are all part of what the brookings
institution calls the success
sequence for stable families getting at
least a high school diploma
working and then marrying before having
children
research by sociologists brad wilcox and
wendy wang
showed that only three percent of
millennials who did these three things
were in poverty
by the time they reached adulthood we
can teach this promote this put money
behind this message
finish high school get a job get married
family parenting the way we raise our
kids it's the most important issue
facing america
and we barely talk about it well on this
show we
will talk about it we will fight for the
reconstruction
of the american family the next
revolution we need
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else